elle s'exprime avec des gestes des sauts
des couleurs en mouvement également
elle monte en intensité depuis une
dizaine d'années en martinique
l'indianité attise de plus en plus la
curiosité
du tambour qu' on n'a pas l'habitude
d'entendre du tambour comme ça et c'est
bien c'est vraiment ils sont très doués
a vu qu'il y avait beaucoup d'énergie et
on a tous les deux beaucoup à face et je
connaissais pas du tout j'ai vu à la
télé des fois mais on dirait comme ça je
pense que ça me rase à m'apportera
beaucoup
vous savez on se cultive c'est comme ça
qu'on se cultive un les vieux qu'eux
allez on les accepte pas les jeunes
mettant les jeunes noirs
on verra dans la vienne pour que
continue sur tout ce que nos parents
nous avaient laissé sa cuve a voulu pour
penser à nos ancêtres les lie sont
contents moi quand je suis là que je
pense que mon papa lé là ici abbas point
que le fief de la communauté indienne
ont fait les lumières le divali cette
fête concerne également tous les indiens
de la caraïbe c'est trinidadien en sont
la preuve
dans leurs valises le terrain ce tambour
que l'on entend souvent dans les
mariages indiens lundi en martinique
c'est l'occasion de mélanger nos
cultures
nous adorons rencontrer différentes
personnes ou jouer cool chez les
guadeloupéens avant de rentrer en scène
ou chauffe la peau du tambour l'objectif
est de l'attendre pour avoir un bon son
selon leurs croyances cela permet de
mieux communiquer avec les dieux vous
avez une longue et très molle donc
forcément le son il y est pas du tout
vous avez pas pouvoir on choisit quoi
que ce soit vous entendez le le champ
qui fait avec son tombeau les
trinidadiens c'est exactement ça c'est
sans qu'on aura mais avec beaucoup plus
de mains de de traçabilité de marquage
donc on pouvoir cherche sûrement les
zones trouver des zones de marquage
beaucoup plus facilement donc on n'aura
pas des sons un peu à jour 10 ans les
vêtements la cuisine sont aussi un pan
de la culture indienne
cette journée a donc une invitation à la
découverte et surtout l'occasion de
rassembler la martinique ce thème là
c'est à faire ressortir l'indianité qui
est devant nous tous en fait c'est
surtout pour qu'un petit clin d'oeil à
notre métissage en martinique nous
sommes choqués de la fête des lumières
se poursuit demain en danse est un champ
à basse-pointe le carrefour de
l'indianité
[Musique]